be patient so if America is going to
leave this part of the world on its own
I think it's even more important that
Ukraine and Poland establish good
relations to try to change the
environment there whether that's Belarus
or and some more utopian sense Russian
political culture and Russia's future
now you're also within Europe there's
one other country that or at least one
other culture that has in the past and I
think at least with some diminished
sense in the present continues to pay
some attention to Poland in Ukrainian s
Germany I don't think France has much
I'm talking as a scholar from my
scholarly contacts as president of the
International Association of the
membership of german-speaking countries
and the number of chairs that devote are
devoted to the study of Polish and
Ukrainian subjects the only other
country that really the only other
countries that really seem to play any
role here are Germany and Austria for
for different reasons in different
contexts of different historical
experiences and one would like to
believe too that Germany in particular
with its still considerable economic
wealth and political clout in the union
might be enlisted in this polish
Ukrainian project or the series of
Polish Ukrainian projects there are
people in Germany and Austria who are
are deeply concerned about things
farther east and and keep trying to
raise their fellow-citizens
consciousness about these countries and
their faiths and realize i think the
stakes that they face if things go worse
farther east
and the geopolitical situation is
redrawn in a way this unfavorable to to
the new European community so Germany
and again as a historian I think Germany
offers both Poland and Ukraine a much
better example of how to deal with one's
past then even the United States which
often it seems to be so overwhelming and
overweening that we tend to turn off
countries that we try to help with our
even when we don't mean to with our sort
of unconscious arrogance and especially
these days with our strange foreign
policy and lack of respect for
international institutions but in terms
of Germany Germany's long post warfare
gannon heights badelt eagle has I think
resulted in a Germany with a new kind of
democratic civic consciousness one that
has been willing to take responsibility
for its past mistakes and sins and
blunders and which I think Poland has
already begun to emulate in some sense
in the adverb my discussions and Ukraine
is doing even a much better job at this
then certainly Russia in confronting its
fit Soviet past its Nazi past and I I
would hope again that Germany might be a
positive model for the kind of
transformation of political conscience
as we noted yesterday there was a great
deal more consensus to be reached on
earlier topics of the 16th and 18th
century by the time he got to the end of
the day people were hardly speaking to
each other on things about World War two
so I'm glad that at least professor
Polanski ended the day on a relatively
positive no
of the ghetto it's the Gatorade story
began to rise Ukrainian story I don't
think I had that much more to say I may
be provoked a few comments from the
audience but I think I mainly wanted to
try to sum up my my sense of what we
heard and my view as a as a scholar of
the region and one who visits frequently
I usually visit Kiev and Moscow on the
same trip and so I have some comparative
comparative social science conclusions I
usually draw from those trips but last
time it was interesting to go from
Warsaw to the veal to Kiev and then to
Moscow to see the change in political
culture from from west to east which
still is very palpable in that part of
the world so thank you for coming and
paying attention and taking part in this
and again let's hope for the best for
the positive things after all coming
back to my utopian scheme of
transforming Russia was if this happens
it wouldn't be the first time if you
remember the key of Slovenia Draco
latina academia which was a major
conduit for Western mostly polish or
polarized European ideas to modernize
the Russian state at various times and
Poland and Ukraine have played important
roles in introducing Russia to European
ideas from farther west I hope it's not
a complete pipe dream although I realize
there are those in this audience who
feel that and again if it can be done
through civil society I think that's the
only way it can be done through the
state's at this point it would be a lot
more different a lot more difficult and
organizing a joint polish Ukrainian
Russian military units in Iraq doesn't
sound like the right way to go either or
a very likely pasa
delays so thank you
come to the end of our conference thank
you for coming Thank You panelists who
look forward to seeing you again perhaps
a bullet in your brain maybe your review
our commutes in any case it'll be ten